bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où j'aimerais
qu'on parle ensemble sobrement de ce qui
vient récemment d'arrivé c'est le cas de
Kang le Conquérant vous êtes désormais
tous au courant Jonathan majors l'acteur
de Kang dans quantumania et loky a été
viré par Marvel studio suite à son
procès où il a été reconnu coupable de
violence et d'harcèlement j'aihésitaé à
vous en parler car le sujet est un petit
peu particulier quand même on ne va pas
se mentir mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir ensemble ce qu'il
pourrait advevenir concernant le futur
du MCU car c'est quand même un
tremblement de terre pour l'univers des
films c'est un gros chamboulement je
suis très curieux d'avoir vos avis en
commentaire le but de cette vidéo c'est
simplement d'échanger par rapport à la
situation actuellement rien n'est fixe
concernant le futur de Marvel tout ce
qui
dit peut clairement changer bref voyons
ensemble tranquillement comment tout ça
peut évoluer bon en vrai on pourrait se
dire que la solution est simple pour
Marvel studio soit on recaste
c'est-à-dire qu'on engage un nouvel
acteur pour kangle conquérrent et rien
ne change ou bien on délaisse le
personnage et on commence à se
concentrer sur une nouvelle menace
notamment docteur Doom ou Fatalis si
vous préférez mais en vrai je trouve que
c'est quand même bien plus complexe que
ça majors a excellé en tant que Kang et
c'est indéniable et le truc c'est que
tout chez Marvel studio tournait autour
de ce nouveau méchant on nous l'a
présenté dans l'oki comme l'être le plus
important de toute la saga en tant que
celui qui demeure hiérarchiquement
parlant il n'y avait pas plus haut que
ce dernier puisqu'il veillait sur le bon
déroulement de toute la saga et qu'en
plus il était l'élément déclencheur
après l'oki pour lancer la guerre
multiverselle guerre où il est l'entité
principale nous avons eu aussi
quantouania où tout le scénario avait
été changé pour maître C au devant de la
scène et en faire une entité centrale
alors que pourtant ce n'était juste
qu'un variant parmi les Kang puis sans
oublier évidemment la fameuse scène post
générique nous dévoilant la totalité de
ces variants avec pour chaque Kang le
même visage celui de Jonathan maers de
quoi en rajouter sur l'iconicité du coup
du personnage et de l'acteur qui
l'incarne en fait si changement de
méchant il y a nous pourrions nous dire
ok ça va Kang est apparu seulement dans
deux œuvres du MC et en plus l'un des
deux a à moitié bidé puisque quantouania
n'a pas été franchement un succès et
nombreux ont été ceux qui ont été déçus
du film même si le personnage de Kang
quant à lui était plutôt quand même
assez apprécié néanmoins Marvel a tout
fait pour le mettre au centre de
l'intrigue au centre de tous les sujets
et c'est là la véritable problématique
dès la première apparition de Kang sous
les traits de celui qui demeure on nous
parle d'une guerre multiverselle la
fameuse guerre de Secret Wars et guerre
où les les principaux acteurs du conflit
sont les autres Kang comme il nous a été
montré c'est eux qui déclencheront le
plus grand conflit que Marvel n'estit
jamais connu et c'est l'un d'eux qui va
le résoudre et après ça du coup bah le
but pour Marvel était de solidifier ce
qui a été instauré dans l'oki pour nous
montrer la menace et nous prouver
l'importance de ce nouveau méchant quand
on prend du recul le TVA l'histoire
entière de l'univers 616 la guerre
multiverselle avenir tout ça c'est parce
que les Kang sont derrière tout est
justifié parce que un ou des Kang ont
fait une action vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et en vrai tout cela rejoint
un fonctionnement que Marvel nous
proposait déjà à la base c'est de faire
du vilain ultime des trois phases une
entité principale par exemple Thanos ils
l'ont tisé pendant 10 longues années
avec des éléments d'intrigue des scènes
postgénériques des personnages liés
comme gamora Nebula ou Ronan par exemple
et surtout vu que les pierres d'infini
étaient toujours plus ou moins au centre
des films et bien vu que Thanos était
relié aux pierres puisqu'il les
convoitait et que c'était son but de les
réunir et bien cela le raccrochait
implicitement à chaque fois à l'histoire
racontée et au final quand Infinity War
est sorti ce qui a rendu je trouve
personnellement le film magistral c'est
que le film n'était pas véritablement un
film Avengers mais plutôt un film sur
Thanos un aboutissement pour le
personnage et on retrouve du coup le
fameux Thanos will return à la fin des
crédits là avec Kang ils étaient en
train de reproduire ce schéma où Kang
prend la place de Thanos les pière
d'infini sont remplacé par le multivers
les timelin ou le temps en quelque sorte
la série Loki avait d'ailleurs fait une
belle symbolique dans son premier
épisode concernant ce procédé et bref
Marvel a décidé pour le MCU de placer
Kang au centre des thématiques du
multivers ils ont fait ce choix et par
conséquent à chaque fois désormais mais
qu'on nous parle de multivers et bien
implicitement on pense à Kang et tout
cela du coup traduit un autre problème
de taille c'est que oui bien évidemment
il y a tout ce concept de l'or où il
faut que tout soit cohérent pour
l'histoire étalée sur les trois
nouvelles phases mais il y a aussi le
délire de l'image si je puis dire ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'en faisant
de Kang une entité centrale dans tout le
multiver et bien actuellement si on
pense multiver dans le MCU on pense à
Kang et pire que ça c'est qu'avec les
performances de Jonathan majors ainsi
que son procès qui a pas mal été
médiatisé car on le savait hein mais
s'il perdait son procès et bien il
perdrait sa place au sein de Marvel et
sans parler du fait également que vu que
Marvel a décidé de faire de Kang le
prochain grand vilain et bien le
personnage lui-même est lui aussi très
médiatisé bah là du coup dans la tête
des gens dans le collectif on va dire
avec tout ce qui s'est passé les
dernières années dont ce fameux procès
actuellement si nous pensons à Kang nous
pensons à Jonathan majors son rôle là
lui colle à la peau que ce soit pour les
bonnes ou les mauvaise raison et ça
c'est un vrai souci pour Marvel car à
force de garder le même acteur pour
jouer un personnage central et récurrent
le rôle est directement associé à
l'acteur ou l'actrice si je vous parle
de Robert dowy junior il a de très très
fortes chances pour que vous pensiez à
Iron Man si je vous parle d'éliizabeth
oldsen pareil de très grandes chances
que vous pensiez à la Scarlet witch l'un
des gros risques du coup avec tout ça
pour le personnage de Kang et bien
c'était que si majors était écarté il y
avait de très grosses chances que Marvel
rentre du coup dans une phase de remise
en question par rapport à leur direction
et leur personnage et en plus autre
problème aussi c'est que qui va vouloir
reprendre le rôle après tout ça nombreux
sont les acteurs qui pourraient incarner
Kang en vrai mais encore faut-il que ces
derniers veuillent bien incarnet Kang
aujourd'hui c'est passé après Jonathan
majors c'est prendre un rôle qui a été
très médiatisé et accessoirement aussi
quand même pas mal critiqué notamment à
cause de certaines directions prises par
Marvel et certains échecs dont notamment
htman quantumania c'est un véritable
challenge en vrai si ricast il y a le
prochain acteur s'engage dans un vrai
défi sur plusieurs longues années du
coup même si le recast est possible et
quand même assez probable et en vrai
personnellement moi c'est ce que je
souhaite je pense vraiment qu'il faut
aller au bout avec Kang il y a quand
même la possibilité que Marvel le dé
laisse pour passer tranquillement à
autre chose histoire déjà que toute
cette histoire se tasse un peu néanmoins
si il délaisse vraiment Kang et bien il
va falloir un nouveau super vilain
beaucoup pensent à docteur Doom mais
personnellement je suis mitigé je pense
que ce serait un bon moyen de gâcher le
personnage alors oui l'avantage c'est
que l'acteur principal de Secret Wars
dans les comics et son grand gagnant
c'est Victor van Doom les prochains
films Avengers respecteraient donc
complètement l'origine des comics tout
comme ils l'ont fait par exemple avec
Thanos concernant la saga Infinity war
néanmoins je trouve que c'est un Paris
très risqué bon déjà le MCU ce n'est pas
les comics même s'il y a une adaptation
assez respectée de certaines histoires
beaucoup d'éléments changent car Marvel
studio fait certains choix et ils font
en fonction de ce qui a été amené dans
les productions dans la saga Infinity
war par exemple le véritable héros de
l'histoire c'est Adam Warlock c'est le
plus grand rival de Thanos dans les
comics et pourtant il était complètement
absent de l'épopé dans les films et ce
n'est pas grave Infinity war était
incroyable mais là Marvel a fait le
choix de se concentrer sur Kang car ils
ont choisi d'en faire l'entité centrale
du multivers et en plus cela colle
d'ailleurs très bien au personnages
puisque vu que le multivers c'est
l'apport d'autres réalités d'autres
mondes comme le nôtre et bien cela
sous-entend la présence d'autres héros
encore inconnu ou encore mieux d'autres
itérations d'un même personnage et ça
c'est un bon respect des comicqu mix par
rapport à Kang où les Avengers sont
affrontés énormément d'itération de ce
personnage qui sont tous nés à partir de
voyage dans le temps qui ont donné
naissance à d'autres branches dans le
multivers et cetera et cetera et du coup
bien avant les prochains films Avengers
Marvel peut se permettre et je dirais
même qu'il devaient le faire c'était de
développer leur nouveau vilains par le
biais d'autres films ou séries avec Loki
et Kantou Mania seulement le personnage
de Kang a déjà été ultra développé quand
on regarde surtout que vu que nous
sommes dans un environnement où le
multivers est omniprésent et bien il ne
faut pas développer seulement qu'un seul
Kang mais il faut développer aussi ses
variants et il était là tout le
challenge avec une échelle multiverselle
il faut faire de Kang une menace pour
chaque univers et je pense qu'il y avait
large moyen de continuer tout ce
développement par le biais d'autres
variants dans d'autres productions
jusqu'à pourquoi pas l'avènement du
prime Kang qui lui sera supérieur aux
autres et cetera et cetera si nous
revenons à Doom actuellement pour le
ramener bah il n'y a encore aucun
développement le concernant il n'existe
même pas encore dans le MCU et surtout
j'ai envie de le dire mais dans le monde
de Marvel bah il y a les vilains et il y
a docteur Doom ce dernier c'est la carte
ultime de Marvel studio qu'il ne faut
pas louper il n'y a pas plus boss final
dans les comics que Fatalis et là nous
sommes au beau milieu de la phase 5 nous
n'avons toujours pas les quatre fantasti
qui sont très liés au personnages nous
n'avons toujours pas de lad veri ou quoi
que ce soit nous n'avons rien cont
concernant le docteur Doom et en plus de
cela les prochaines productions
annoncées que nous connaissons ne
laisseront pas la place pour un tel
développement concernant le docteur sans
même parler des films Avengers car dans
ces derniers nous aurons tellement de
personnages différents qu'il n'y aura
pas de temps véritable pour bien
développer Doom dans Infinity war ils
ont plus se permettre avec Thanos car
c'était l'aboutissement de 10 années de
teasing et développement comme on l'a
dit en vrai je vais vous dire nous en
avons peu parler sur la chaîne je
comptais le faire un jour mais c'est un
peu l'occasion d'en parler ici mais pour
moi la meilleure façon d'introduire de
docteur Doom c'est de reproduire le même
procédé que la série loky Avengers
endgame signifiait la fin des trois
premières phases et par conséquent le
début d'un nouveau cycle un cycle où le
multiver serait au cœur de tout par
conséquent grâce à l'utilisation du
voyage dans le temps dans Avengers
endgame une erreur a été commise par les
Avengers et Loki a pu s'échapper ce qui
a modifié l'histoire et donner naissance
à une nouvelle réalité un nouveau loky
et ce dernier par la suite nous a amené
tout toutes les thématiques importantes
pour les prochaines phases pour que ce
soit plus clair j'ai toujours pensé
qu'il fallait rester à fond sur Kang
jusqu'à la fin d'Avengers Secret Wars
qu'on règle toutes ces questions liées
au multivers et que l'on gère son
effondrement dans Secret Wars car c'est
ça la finalité de Secret Wars avant par
la suite du coup de nous proposer une
sorte de reboot mais durant le film
Secret Wars qui symbolise la fin de ce
nouveau cycle de la même manière que
Loki il nous faudrait un teasing durant
l'popé de l'avenir et c'est là où Doom
pourrait intervenir quelque chose du
style ou pendant l'effondrement du
multivers ou pendant la renaissance de
ce dernier quelque chose émerge
discrètement je dis n'importe quoi mais
après le reboot par exemple nous
pourrions avoir l'apparition de la lat
verie qui n'existait pas auparavant qui
n'était pas dans l'univers 616 et qui
serait là parce qu'elle aurait fusionner
avec un autre univers c'est une idée
comme ça ou bien quelque chose du style
Doom a sur vécu dans son coin à
l'effondrement du multiver il s'était
déjà préparé et cetera tu vois avant
finalement de revenir et il aurait du
coup conscience du multivver précédent
bref je donne des idées comme ça
quelconque mais en gros quelque chose
qui permettent de teser la future menace
et les nouvelles thématiques à partir du
tout dernier film de ce nouveau cycle
comme Loki avec Kang quand on regarde
les trois premières phases nous étions à
l'échelle d'un univers nous étions très
orienté sur l'espace avec les pierres
d'infini et pendant qu'on réglait cette
question des pierres d'infini avec le
voyage dans le temps et bien la
thématique du multivers est arrivée très
discrètement implicitement par le biais
de Loki durant ce même film et je pense
que c'est ce procédé qu'il faudrait
réutiliser pour docteur Doom surtout que
cela ferait une belle référence du coup
à Secret Wars des comics parce que Doom
est clairement lié à tout ce concept là
c'est là où il brille le plus
personnellement je trouve bref pour
conclure je dirais qu'il faut aller au
bout avec Kang et qu'il faut recast le
personnage c'est le mieux à faire ils se
sont trop engagés avec Kang ils en ont
fait trop une entité importante et
centrale dans le scénario de ce nouveau
cycle multiversel néanmoins il faut
trouver l'acteur qui voudra bien passer
après Jonathan major et qui voudra
s'engager sur ce rôle très médiatisé
pendant plusieurs années par conséquent
à mon avis il faut prendre le temps et
laisser Kang de côté pour le moment
toute façon il y a plein d'autres
histoires à raconter il y a plein
d'autres projets de prévu cela va
permettre de moins sacraliser Kang et
laisser respirer un peu le personnage
avant de pourquoi pas du coup le faire
revenir comme il faut dans les années à
venir voilà sur ce je suis content
d'avoir pu parler de tout ça avec vous
je trouvais que c'était important d'en
parler et j'en avais vraiment envie je
suis très curieux de vous lire et
d'échanger avec vous sur le sujet car
c'est un petit peu inédit en vrai comme
situation on se retrouve très vite pour
de grosses vidéos c'était targoroc allez
ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde